i want to start today with genuinely
just very good news you might remember
that last week on monday we learned that
pfizer reported that their vaccine
in their data is shown to be 90
effective at preventing coronavirus
infections it was not yet peer reviewed
this morning just hours ago moderna
based
here in boston says that its vaccine is
94.5 percent effective
in preventing covid19 this is
interim data from a late stage clinical
trial
data on which they will be seeking
immediate emergency youth
use authorization to start vaccinating
people
and we are very quickly pointed in the
direction of course
pending those approvals of the u.s
having
two vaccines authorized for emergency
use by december
with as many as 40 to 60 million
doses available and being distributed
by the end of this year moderna's
interim analysis was based on
95 infections among participants
who received either the placebo or a
vaccine
of those 95 people who got the virus
only five had received the vaccine
the other 90 had received a placebo in
other words
not the vaccine this was with the two
doses
28 days apart as is expected to be
the sort of eventual protocol for this
vaccine
also very important the data from
modernist 30 000
participant trial showed that the
people who got the vaccine and got
coronavirus in other words that roughly
five percent
who despite having the vaccine were not
completely protected
seemed to have significantly less
serious cases of coronavirus so
that's a question that's still in the
air about the pfizer vaccine
one of the other major differences
between the moderna and the pfizer
vaccine is that unlike the pfizer
vaccine
the moderna vaccine requires only
standard
refrigeration one of the issues with the
pfizer vaccine was that it requires
refrigeration
well below the temperatures that like a
typical flu vaccine
might require and so from an
infrastructure standpoint
the moderna vaccine also having huge
huge
promise just as far as the ease of
distribution
and it simplifies infrastructure
requirements dramatically
the pfizer vaccine has to be shipped and
stored at minus 70 c
70 celsius and that's certainly a
challenge so
you couldn't ask for better news of
course we need to go through the process
peer reviewing the data getting that
emergency use authorization if you don't
trust the fda
these are vac we now have two vaccines
that are going to be presumably seeking
approval in other countries as well so
if you trust
a different country's health agency as
you would not be crazy to to do during a
time when
the fda and cdc have been so politicized
by the trump administration
you will have uh presumably approvals
from other countries
as well at least before the vaccine is
widely available to people of
all ages and uh i i think it makes sense
to mention
um it does not seem like these companies
and from what i've seen
the modernist ceo to me has always
seemed like a guy on the up and up
um the development in germany with
bioentech
and this turkish immigrant couple of the
what is now being called the pfizer
vaccine so far
the point i'm trying to make is i've not
seen evidence that either of these
individuals are running organizations
that would try to get approval for their
vaccine before it was ready trump wanted
them to do it as quickly as possible
trump said 100 million doses in october
uh and i would have been worried if that
had happened because it seemed like it
would have been too soon
december based on the data we now have
seems logical
and uh that's sort of where my head is
right now now i want to mention one
other thing
um you start doing the math okay if we
have two vaccines
60 million doses in december you need
two doses so that would be like
for 30 million people that's only 10 9
of the country
and then maybe you get another total uh
for 35 million people in january if you
start doing math and it seems like it's
going to be a long time
before any of us will be able to get a
vaccine the latest surveys indicate
that 40 percent of the country doesn't
have any plan to get this vaccine
now that represents potential herd
immunity issues
but separately remember if 40 of the
country
doesn't want the vaccine 400 million
doses would be enough for everybody
who wants the vaccine to get both
doses that they need 28 days apart
so the point is it's bad that 40 of the
country doesn't want the vaccine
from a herd immunity standpoint you and
i
if you are in sort of my demographic uh
uh
sort of position age and health range um
you and i may be able to get a vaccine
far sooner
as a result of having hopefully two
approved vaccines
and 40 of the country not wanting it it
does raise longer term questions though
about 40
of the country not wanting the vaccine
we have a possible game changer here
let's not get ahead of ourselves we've
seen faucion vaccine timeline be more
optimistic lately than we've ever seen
him
and if things go the way they are
pointing we could have a second half of
2021
that looks dramatically better than
2020.
i don't want to make any more hyperbolic
claim than that i'm not
even thinking of things like completely
back to normal but in the meantime
masks distancing not having huge indoor
thanksgivings
all of those things have to continue
because we're back up to 1500 people a
day dying
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist
lets you consume an entire book on your
way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
pacman i've put the link right
underneath this video